Terry and Tiffany are with us hey guys
how are you doing well how are you do
better than I deserve where are you from
we are from the lexington kentucky area
we live in Hertzberg ah well welcome to
Nashville thanks for coming down to join
us what hour and a half or so to get
down here no sir it's about three is it
oh I missed that Wow boom act like I
don't know what I'm doing that's good
so here to do a debt-free scream how
much have you paid off we have paid off
a hundred and forty four thousand
dollars I love it and how long did that
take
it took us forty four months and I'm
making what kind of money during that
time about one hundred and fifty
thousand good for you what do you guys
do for a living I'm an assistant
principal at a Mercer County senior high
school go Titans and my wife Tiffany
works in HR at Kentucky School for the
Deaf oh very cool good so a hundred and
forty-four thousand lots of student
loans or what Tiffany had a student loan
from way back but it was only about
fifty fifteen thousand but unfortunately
we had 16 credit cards that we had to
pay off to two vehicles so we were in a
mess Wow absolutely so sixteen credit
cards yes sir I mean just like every
store you went to well we we convinced
ourselves that we had enough money that
anything we wanted if we could make the
payment we could buy yeah so we just
kept building lots of debt oh my gosh
and how much of this debt was car debt
um probably fifty thousand dollars okay
Wow yeah like 60 70 thousand dollars in
credit card debt it was a mess
Wow Wow Wow what happened forty four
months ago cause you just change it
change your wicked ways I'll be honest I
was definitely hiding things and not
really communicating well with with what
I was doing with the money because I was
paying the bills and I was real
frustrated one day at work and was
talking to a colleague of mine and they
mentioned a Financial Peace University
Tiffany had been on a trip and when she
came back she had told me she had been
listening to the show so that's where we
came to agreement that we needed to do
something different to improve our
lifestyle for two different
conversations we showed up in both of
them and then
and you got okay we got to do something
different so Tiffani he comes in and
goes ah I gotta tell you I made a mess
what'd you say I had no idea I knew that
we made a lot of money and we were
spending a lot I had no idea why is he
still alive cuz I bought whenever I
wanted about Oh cuz okay you were
complicit okay alright so you had a good
life even though you just stuck your
head in the sand okay I got you alright
that's good he wasn't really lying he
was just trying to carry the load by
himself and wasn't telling you
absolutely oh that's sort of like lying
but yeah okay Wow
but I mean when you looked at it Tiffani
what how did you feel when you first
really looked at the total numbers I was
overwhelmed I was over whim
absolutely overwhelmed had no idea at
all at all that was a long night wasn't
it
it was yeah well it was the second it
was a second class we went to for
financial peace and we had to write
everything down mm-hmm and I was so
embarrassed that we had 22 debts and I
and I didn't know where to even start it
was so overwhelming but we just we got
in it together and just wanted to make
things so much better and we have three
little girls and aww we just want to be
a better example for them yeah we just
we just fought fought fought until you
just listed them smallest to largest sir
and knocked out the little one yes sir
what was the very first one you paid off
it was a JCPenney yard was the first one
yeah and how much was you remember $26
and 24 sell of it so now we're down to
15 cards okay yes you go so it's just
you know that does it sounds kind of
silly but you're like okay maybe we can
do this yes sir
there's a little bit of glimmer of hope
at Pat right after the overwhelming
moment then absolutely okay we're just
going to begin to eat this elephant a
bite at a time and 44 months almost four
years later you've got this thing beat
down to nothing and no dad at all how
long have you two been married 12 years
have you ever been debt-free during the
12 years until now until now not now the
car drives different
yeah I'm gonna keep drought in to live
falls apart yeah oh man this is quite an
emotional experience for you all yes I'm
still emotion that's okay you have a
right to be you ought to be proud of
yourself that's a good reason to be
emotional so what do you tell people
that the keys to getting out of debt are
because this is a very impressive walk
you've walked I'm you honestly until you
get to the point that you're a truly
sick and tired of being sick and tired
it's it's almost impossible we've
watched other people that have tried it
that didn't have much success I don't
think they really bought into it but
until you just decide that you want a
better life for you and for your family
and you want to be a better example to
other people it's it's tough and that's
that's all that we did he's got mad
absolutely absolutely
yeah so Tiffany when you're looking at
that and you wrote it all down that
first night and it's all completely
overwhelming what point later on did it
stop being overwhelming and you're
thinking I think we can do this how far
into the process were you I would say
just maybe the second or third month
okay when we started I'm doing the
armello system and start trying to
compete to see who was going to have
money left so we can figure out where to
put that on an extra bill and we start
really competing about okay you know I
was doing the grocery shopping and I was
trying to make sure that I buy
everything I needed but I wanted to have
some money left over so I can put it on
a different bill so that's when we just
start real that's when I really start
saying we can do this we don't do this
and he was bought in from the very
beginning I mean within the third or
fourth class he was and he loved it so
much he decided that he wanted to teach
a class I was like we haven't learned
what we need to learn yet but he's ready
to teach a class and we did and just and
it's just start moving mm-hmm yeah you
don't have to be perfect to teach your
class that's a good thing because we
wouldn't have any classes
because we don't have any perfect people
but actually what ends up happening is
people walking with you is you're the
coordinator it it not only inspires you
makes you accountable but it also
inspires them that you're doing it so
I'm sure you found that as you
coordinated the class yes yeah very cool
they can tell you one more things sure
before we started and we had so much
that I was wanting to figure out how I
could get rid of it the easy way and
Tiffany she told me she said you know we
created this debt and it's our
responsibility to take care of it and so
I was so thankful that she convinced me
of that as we were as we got started
with this program so you looked at
bankruptcy I did you had to emotionally
consider it because it's overwhelming
yeah but then she says now we got
backbone we can do this we got 150,000
our income we made this mess we can
clean it up and you know the beauty of
that is once you've done this you can do
anything absolutely mean this is you
you've been you've looked right straight
in the face of the tiger and and he
blinked I mean you got it this is very
very cool well congratulations what's
the one debt that when you paid it off
you went I hate you people I'm glad
you're gone it probably hurt student
loan because that student don't start it
before we ever even met it been forever
it had been and so I we were definitely
ready to stomp that one yeah get Sallie
Mae out of the house it's tired of her
having her own bedroom all these years
you know that's very cool very cool
you guys are amazing it's a great story
anything I mean you fought and fought
and clawed your way through this and you
won and it's just it's victory
congratulations thank you to meet you
very cool Terry and Tiffany Lexington
Kentucky one hundred and forty-four
thousand dollars in debt they paid it
all off in 44 months making a hundred
and fifty a year count it down let's
hear a debt free scream three two one
we're dead free
I love it I love it I love it
awesome awesome awesome very cool
Oh